welcome to the industrial Environmental
Management lecture series on business in
the environment
I'm Reed lips at associate
the industrial environmental management
program and chair of the lecture series
here at the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies through this
lecture series started in 1991 we seek
to bring corporate executives and others
to Yale to talk about topics of current
interest and in many cases cutting-edge
developments in Environmental Management
policy and technology we value the
additional perspective that
businesspeople bring to our discussions
at the school and the opportunity to
have students and faculty meet them and
for them to meet us in the past we've
explored such topics as the
environmental impact of the service
industries how breakthrough technology
has created new environmental markets
and green domestic markets in developing
countries the lecture series is
supported by a small endowment the Jol
AmeriCorps ihara fund joel attended the
environment school in the school of
management and graduated in 1992 he went
to work for Conrail and was active in
the global environmental management
initiative joel was very bright very
committed and they're in a very
energetic believer in the importance of
greening corporate practice when he died
17 years ago conrail his colleagues
family and friends established a
memorial fund to honor him his parents
asked that the funds be used to support
the series because they think it
captures well his commitment to dialogue
about business in the environment this
year were fortunate to have a special
lecture series with additional support
from Nestle waters North America the
theme is producers packaging and public
policy the lecture series explores the
topic of extended producer
responsibility EPR and packaging EPR is
a policy strategy that makes producers
responsible for their products when they
become waste the goal of the series this
year is to explore the advantages and
disadvantages of the application of EPR
to packaging waste and municipal solid
waste more generally in the US Nestle
waters North America the market leader
in bottled water in the US and a
division of Nestle sa the global food
and beverage company is seeking to
significantly improve the recycling of
beverage containers and all recyclable
packaging materials the lecture series
has hosted 8 talks related to packaging
and EPR
ranging from background topics such as
the role of plastic packaging and marine
debris and how or whether
biodegradability might resolve some
packaging waste problems to topics more
specific to EPR such as the history of
the use of this policy strategy in the
US and the extensive Canadian experience
with EPR to bring this lecture series to
close it seemed fitting to invite Kim
Jeffery the CEO of Nestle waters North
America to talk mr. Jeffrey and Nestle
Waters have played a prominent role in
advocating EPR for packaging in the US
and then working to put it on the policy
agenda
they've taken a very public stance in
promoting EPR and one that is somewhat
at odds with some others in the beverage
and packaging industries Kim Jeffery has
been president and CEO of Nestle Waters
North America since 1992 he oversees the
largest bottled water company in the US
with 10 brands including Perrier and
Poland Springs over 9,000 employees 27
plants more than 100 facilities and 4.2
billion dollars in sales in 2010 mr.
Jeffery joined the company in 1978 a
Central Division sales manager over the
following years he advanced to lead
posts in sales marketing operations
processing to executive vice president
and chief operating officer before
assuming the company's top position
because of the success of mr. Jeffery
and Nestle in introducing EPR into many
four oh we're not asking mr. Jeffery to
present an introductory lecture on this
topic instead we seek to take the
discussion to the next level
EP are 2.0 as it were by having a
conversation thus the title of this
event will start with some discussion
between mr. Jeffery and me for about 30
minutes and then in the second half of
the event we'll open the floor to
questions the event is being recorded
and will be available on the website of
the school along with the previous
lectures will send the web address to
those who sign the guest list in front
of a lecture hall if you want to view
those recordings before we start our
discussion let me provide some
background for those of you who are not
familiar with EPR extended producer
responsibility originated in the
late 1980s when a Swedish academic
coined the term reflecting policy
discussions that were taking place in
Sweden and Germany the notion behind EPR
is that if producers were made
responsible for the management of their
products when they become waste then
producers will take into account waste
related issues when the products or
packages are designed making them more
recyclable for instance thus making
recyclable recycling or related
activities less expensive more feasible
and when hopes
accomplishing environmental goals the
intent is that the cost of waste
management will be internalized in the
price of products because the producers
are bearing those costs products that
are easy to recycle will be cheaper and
thus will have a competitive advantage
over those that do not PR was first
adopted in the major way in the 1990
1990s when Germany enacted a widely
discussed law the packaging ordinance
and established a second or parallel
waste management system for packaging
funded by producers producers paid a fee
to an industry consortium and when then
permitted to print a green dot on their
packages indicating to consumers that
that package could be recycled through
the new system thus the costs were
shifted from local governments to
producers and consumers and a new
institution the Green Dot Program was
born this concept spread through Europe
with the enactment of the European
Union's packaging directive and on to
East Asia Canada and to a lesser extent
to the US and Latin America with its
diffusion EPR took on different forms in
some countries EPR for packaging does
not involve a separate collection system
instead municipalities retain their
traditional role for collecting
recyclables along with trash and
producer organizations reimburse some or
all of the costs EPR has been
conspicuously applied to waste
electronics automobiles household
hazardous waste such as paint and
batteries and a variety of other
products in the u.s. legislation
establishing EPR for municipal solid
waste was attempted unsuccessfully at
the federal level in the early 1990s
since then and until recently EPR in the
US has taken two forms for use with
specific household hazardous waste
such as rechargeable batteries and
bottle bills bottle bills our state laws
that establish deposits on beverage
containers typically consumers pay a
nickel when they purchase a beverage
which is refunded when they return the
container for recycling bottle bills are
controversial industry tends to oppose
them because of the cost and
administrative burdens they impose
environmental advocacy organizations
typically support them because of the
high recycling rates for beverage
containers that result those of you in
the audience who are EPR aficionados
will be itching to clarify and contest
my simplistic overview but rather than
engage those nuances I'd like to start
the conversation with the person who has
become one of the most prominent voices
in this debate with that quick summary
let's start the conversation about
remaking recycling in the US the
potential for producer extended producer
responsibility
so let's start with how did you first
learn about EPR and what was it about it
that me he decided that it was something
to support EPR for me came from McMurray
insured ah this morning it was a process
of sort of elimination we've been on a
sustainability journey in our company
for a very long time since we bought our
first business actually in in 1980 we
purchase Poland Spring bottled water
company which was essentially a bankrupt
company at that time doing three and a
half million dollars of revenue and it
came with 29 employees a 50,000 square
foot Butler production building that was
almost falling down and 450 acres of
watershed land that basically protected
the spring source and so our
sustainability journey began that year
if we didn't take care of the resource
we wouldn't have a business and that
extends today with 14,000 acres of
watershed land but as our journey has
has progressed from just taking care of
our property to lightweighting our
packaging to building three and a half
million square feet of LEED certified
manufacturing space we then move outside
our four walls and I set a goal of by
2018 of being responsible for recycling
rate of 60% for all beverage containers
not just ours
it's it's virtually unachievable it's
one of those big hairy audacious goals
out there but what it does do is focuses
you on how do I get there if you want to
if you want to give an earnest effort to
achieve that goal how do I get there
well I first started casting around for
a better bottle bill than the ones we
have today in most states we have 10
states with with
a bottle bill legislation in all but one
the return location is the retailer and
when the retailer is the take back
mechanism you have no way of expanding
it into into more streams of material
California had a bottle bill that that
had recycling centers as the take back
mechanism those were outside of
supermarkets so theoretically you could
expand those to other materials but but
I started thinking and Mary and I
discussed this this morning I started
thinking beyond our containers in in the
evolution of my thinking to all the
streams of materials that we want to get
back today and all the streams of
material in the future that we want to
get back that we don't even know about
today so a year and a half ago I had
sort of an aha moment when I went up to
Toronto to look at their recycling
system they have appe as you throw
system where you end up with a big big
bin for your ideally a big free bin for
your recyclables and a small bin for
your food waste and 20 years ago they
started that system with collecting and
processing three streams of material and
today it's 30 streams of material that
they process and monetize and so my my
evolutionary thinking came from just our
packaging material to thinking about a
system that could capture all streams of
material and if you're going to have a
system like that you've got to have the
high value materials in that system a
bale of recycle of bottles used beverage
bottles today or household items or food
items sells for about 40 cents a pound
so a pound of recycled PT material is
worth 40 cents today that's a high value
material if you have that in another
stream just to take back at the retailer
as a bottle bill you rob the the this a
larger system of the ability to have a
high
material carry a lot of the cost for an
infrastructure that needs to happen and
I guess read that's how I got there -
EPR and I'll let you do the next one so
of the systems that you've been looking
at could you say something about some of
the features that that seem like they
might drive drive you to the goal you
want to get - yes first of all we need a
system that's low cost we need a system
that's very broad the lowest cost system
is going to be a system that is paid for
by suppliers like my manufacturers like
myself who can run a private system that
that invests the money in the right
places for collection for processing and
provides an incentive for manufacturers
to reduce their packaging material use
less of it so whereas we have a bottle
bill in Connecticut and New York that
the retailer's lobbied for a higher
handling fee I envision an EPR system
that could ultimately be lower cost once
the infrastructure is built but but
managed privately so that the money goes
into the right place today a bottle bill
in in Connecticut all the all the
unredeemed deposits go into a black hole
to fill a budget deficit not one cent of
the unredeemed deposits in Connecticut
go for recycling infrastructure in the
state and I think that's a big mistake
so so it would be it would be low cost
it would have everybody in it 40% of
what goes into landfills today I think
read is printed paper plastic of all
kinds is about six six percent so we
have a huge opportunity to get back many
more streams of material and much more
volume than just beverage containers
with it with a system that has every
supplier every manufacturer in it the
the other
that's got to happen with the system
like this is beverage containers are
pervasive we interact with them every
single day I see somebody out here
having a bottle right right in front of
them and a sip out of it right now so we
interact with this packaging there's a
lot of it it's very visible and typical
forms of of curbside don't get too away
from home recycling where a lot of this
beverage is consumed so the numbers are
like this in the United States we have
about 12% availability for
away-from-home recycling with 87 percent
of the places where we consume beverages
today not having a system of being able
to get this material back and used again
so any EPR system has to have a very
strong component for away-from-home
recycling infrastructure so let's talk
about away from home what percentage of
your bottles are consumed away from home
I have no idea but I'm guessing a lot I
would say it's it's somewhere between 50
and 60% probably and and are there
programs out there that strike you as as
being novel or is there something that
you would want to take us a model are
there how is it that we're gonna get
beyond what we're doing now
well we're building that today we were
we were part of a pilot program in
Manitoba for an an EPR program that we
think is very close to what we'd like to
see in the United States the beverage
companies in Manitoba were the first are
the first people in we are we are there
there is a a fee of two cents a bottle
for every bottle purchased that the the
consumer product companies are charging
out it's being run privately and and
it's two cents for the first couple of
years because building out and away from
home recycling infrastructure is very
very expensive think about the number of
places you could have bins on this
college campus that where you need to
have them but you don't
it's just one place and and when you've
got an 87 percent deficit or 88 percent
deficit in away from home recycling it's
a very expensive cost what we're doing
in Manitoba is charging 2 cents a bottle
until we build the system out and at
which point in time we think 1 cent is
going to be all that's needed to enhance
the rest of the infrastructure on on on
pickup and processing so and and and
ultimately everybody who produces a
packaging material will be in the queue
contributing to this system
although beverages first so we like the
way Manitoba is operating we think
there's tremendous good faith on the
part of the beverage companies to be the
first people in we we recognize that
building out that part of the
infrastructure is unique to beverage
companies and and needs to get paid for
so have you come across many programs
that are having the recovery rates away
from home that you would like to achieve
well this is this is a problem because
we're building the system out in in
Manitoba right now we think we're gonna
get rates up to 50 or 60 percent with
with away from home a good curbside or
single stream pickup and the right and
obviously at the right at the end of the
day you got to have the right kind of
processing because you want to use this
material again you can't have it
contaminated but we think we haven't got
out the system yet we we don't have an
early read on on where where we are but
we think we're gonna get from 50 to 60
percent
so you mentioned Toronto is an
inspiration that most of the Canadian
provinces use the model where the
municipalities collect and the producers
reimburse them in some way and Ontario
unlike Manitoba has had a history of
really acrimonious politics about that
well yeah we don't want to run a new
system we would like and this is where
you get into Devils in the details on
extended producer responsibility cuz
there's lots of different ways to skin
the cat here
we would like to be able to use
infrastructures that are out there today
but but these need to be augmented
because you know what I was saying this
morning 15 years ago this material
didn't have the value that it's got
today today there's more demand for
recycled plastic then there is
availability and that's one of the
reasons why a bit of reach of recycled
PE T it cost so much money so there is a
lot of money in trash today and and you
see more and more people getting into it
private equity is entering it as a
matter of fact when private equity is
chasing around in in this segment you
know something's about to happen for the
future so I think that that that our
goal is not to restructure the systems
that are out there but there to support
them and grow them if if the if the
state if a state were to set the goal
for us then it's a job of Industry to
hit the goal and you've got a pot of
money to do it so so you you you've got
to take care of the pickup piece of it
you've got to take care of the of the
processing part I believe that that that
we have to pick up a hundred percent of
the cost here not to the extent where
we're subsidizing people who are already
profitable Reed you've got it you've got
to take a closer look at the system in
total and this is where the Devils in
the details but basically I envision a
privatized system that picks up the
burden of the cost and allocates the
money into the right places one of the
things that's going to be critical is
getting this material back in a form we
can use it if if PE T material is is too
contaminated when we try to turn it back
into a virgin resin we end up with high
acid aldehyde benzene at parts per
billion in excess of where you would
want for a food grade product so the the
the processing is a very very important
part of this extended producer
responsibility
so if you need high-grade to produce the
recycled content bottles that you want
to make and right now that only comes
from bottle bill recovery no no no no no
how much of your we're buying we're
buying we're buying PE tea for our
brands from multiple places in the
United States and and it's not all about
a bill what percentages I couldn't I
couldn't tell you what I couldn't tell
you what percentage is isn't isn't but I
can tell you that in in California where
there there is bottle bottle bill
we're having trouble right now we're
gonna have anybody from the West Coast
Arrowhead is our brand out in California
50% of all the Arrowhead produced in
California I'm sorry all the arrowhead
produced in California is gonna have 50%
recycled content in it by the middle of
this year we we have been partnering
with a firm out there who's built a
state of the art recycling facility even
with bottle building material they're
having trouble right now getting to the
level we need them to get to if you're a
soft drink company you don't care so
much about acetaldehyde and and and the
and the other other stuff that's in it
because you've got something with color
flavor and sugar to mask the taste but
in a bottle water container all you've
got it it's the water so you've got to
be very very careful with the grade of
PE T and they're having trouble getting
there even at a bottle bill state so
there's a there's a piece of this reed
that's processing there's a piece of it
that's it's contamination of the
material coming in you can take
contaminated material and when I say
contaminated contaminated with other
other forms of plastic in there that
will that will react improperly and we
so some of its in the sorting material
in the plant up front some of its in the
sorting material a sorting process at
the at the recycling center
you know we discussed this this morning
it some recycling centers in America are
big big warehouses with a front loader
truck scooping the stuff into corners
and others are high high-tech single
stream recycling facilities like we have
in Hartford so it's complicated but it's
not just one answer in terms of the
incoming material so the vision is
backing on some of the existing
infrastructure getting more stuff by
building out the system so they're more
places that people can can put their
stuff
where are the cost efficiencies going to
come from if you're building on a
systemness it already operates well it's
it's not so much cost efficiencies as as
it is availability of supply we this is
an upside-down equation I'm going to
give you recycle content resin today
cost fifteen percent more than Virgin
resin and for those of you who studied
this you you you would recognize that
when you recycle just about any
packaging material you save a minimum 50
percent of the energy it takes to make
virgin material and all these materials
whether it's corrugated or plastic
they're all energy so why is is recycled
content resin more expensive than virgin
and when are we going to have a viable
market for alternative materials like
this when it's 15% more than virgin the
answer is never but the reason is that
we get 30% of our containers back and
there's more demand than there is supply
we compete for recycled content with
China on the west coast they're buying
vast quantities of our recycled plastic
to ship to China to make fiber because
when cotton is expensive the competitor
for cotton that's cheaper is-is-is resin
is polyester and when cotton is cheap we
have more available supply of polyester
but but packaging for PE T polyester
materials is the lowest is what is a
small small user relative to the textile
industry so you think that expanding the
supply will basically drive down the
price basically we can buy we can buy
recycled Corrigan for our packaging
material today at prices cheaper than
virgin resin or virgin Corrigan the
reason for that is that the
they're the the largest recycled
corrugate manufacturer in the United
States has new technology and is able to
produce light-weighted corrugate which
which the legacy manufacturers of
corrugate can't produce today so if I if
we can buy if we can buy corrugate at
prices the same as virgin why can't we
buy PT resin at the same price there's
more availability of paper and corrugate
in the United States to meet the demand
that's out there so how are you gonna
convince the grocery manufacturers
that's my biggest problem today I'm
probably the only consumer product
company guy in America who would get up
in front of you today and talk about
this stuff the way I'm talking about it
and the grocery manufacturers if if the
grocery Manufacturers Association was
run by the sustainability directors or
the companies we wouldn't have any
problem he's run by the government
affairs guys and therein lies the
problem almost all of the consumer
products companies in America have
operations in Europe they're operating
under EPA laws in Europe and yet they're
opposing the ones that the EPR ideas
that we're proposing in the United
States and they've been told that it's
gonna cost them fifteen or twenty
billion dollars I'm not sure that that's
the cost because if you want to if you
want to be opposed to something you can
go to anybody who can give you an
estimate it's in the neighborhood of
what you want if I was hiring a
consulting for a month and I was GM a
I'd hire the consulting firm that would
give me the highest cost of EPR and then
I I spread that out to you guys the
reality is that that none of these
manufacturers are thinking about the
possibility of actually lowering their
cost of raw materials by having a robust
infrastructure to get this material back
we buy 400 million pounds of PT resin a
year we make all of our own packaging we
make 20 billion bottles a year in our
manufacturing facilities all
light-weighted and all inside our plants
so we don't have to ship empty bottles
into our plants the there are now about
four major resin suppliers in the world
a couple of them Asian there's been huge
consolidation in the PT resin business
because new capacities come on in Asia
high-tech modern manufacturing
techniques for resin making the resin
manufacturers in America who are working
with legacy systems who have an invested
capital to stay on top of their business
obsolete
so I envision a world where with an
oligopoly of three or four manufacturers
making resin in the world do you think
I'm gonna be able to negotiate a really
good price with one of them or are they
gonna be telling me what I'm gonna be
paying for resin in the future I see I
see a robust environment where we can
use recycled content for our products as
a way of disintermediating and oligopoly
that's out there going to charge us a
lot of money for our products and none
of the manufacturers are thinking to the
endgame where I could actually produce
my products for less by having raw
materials that cost less because they
say 50 to 70% of the energy that it
takes to make virgin materials so how
are you gonna get them to buy this well
we I'm gonna be having to work on this
for a long time and I've been here 34
years I'm not going to be spending too
much more time as CEO of this company
but I'm gonna I'm going to continue to
bang the drum on on this issue we have
provided the seed money for a
organization called recycling reinvented
there's a website as a website up
Michael okay because you can go to the
website and check out what we're doing
where we're working with stakeholders
NGOs and consumer product companies
where they'll talk to us
and manufacturers of these materials
where they will talk to us to start to
have a dialogue around what I call 21st
century recycling infrastructure for our
country we're way behind the curve in
the United States we need to do
something about it there's no money in
in municipal government state government
federal government of the eight hundred
billion dollars of stimulus three years
ago not one nickel went to recycling
infrastructure in the United States
frankly if I could make a political
announcement we would rather invest five
hundred million dollars in Solyndra and
watch it go belly-up instead of creating
some real green jobs and cut carbon
emissions reductions in something that's
standing right in front of us every day
and and this is going to take time it's
gonna take us we're talking to a half a
dozen states that don't have bottle
bills today about EPR legislation we
need one one state to give us a model
that we can look at to compare other
forms of recycling and other systems of
recycling against so that we can start
to have a more intelligent discussion
about where we go for recycling in the
21st century in America so do you see
the the industry folks or the
environmental NGOs is the biggest
barrier in that way environmental NGOs
you know a lot of people still favorite
bottle bills my view on that is they're
narrow they apply to one stream of
materials when we need to get twenty
streams of materials back and we can't
have twenty different systems if we had
the system the kind of system I'm
talking about right now we don't need in
a separate a way system one system can
do everything the example I used this
morning I was nice in the last summer
and a bill McDonagh thing guy that wrote
cradle to cradle and one of the guys on
the trip was Jochen Zeitz who's the CEO
of Puma we had a long discussion about
him wanting to recycle his sneakers but
he's like me he doesn't have any idea
where those sneakers are going and he
doesn't know what happens to them after
they're used but I envisioned a system
where where you know we could have
sneaker week and you know you put out
your sneakers and they get then they get
back to the where they
to get recycled there's no reason why we
can't do this but we can't have 20
different systems we need one the one
best solution for getting the most
material back and and the highest
percentage of the most material back and
it's gonna take a long time Reid I just
think we just need one place to move
forward on this so that we could have a
stalking horse that the rest of society
can look at I just want to say that I
think we essentially have sneaker week
at Yale through Nike that's good so
let's turn to the audience and take some
questions
someone's got a microphone here to pass
around like to follow up on that last
point there where you say that one of
the biggest hurdles right now for
successful EPR is the price that the
recycle content price was too high and I
was wondering if you could say or sort
of guess a or estimate a oil price where
this may flip that the primary cost
would be so expensive that all of a
sudden the recycle content would make
sense it's not so much the oil price
because there's the feedstock for
plastic resin is is not just made up of
oil and essentially it's oil byproducts
the the the real the the real issue here
if I go back to 2008 when the recession
first hit we could buy plastic four or
seven for 15 cents a pound and and today
it's 40 so what happened is demand went
way low against the supply that was
there and the price came down so so it
has less to do with the cost of oil and
more to do with how much material we
have available against the market that's
out there for wanting to use it and and
if we can buy if we can I know the rates
of corrugate recycling are high and
paper I don't know how high but there's
a hell of a lot of paper out there so so
there's there's no question there that
if I can buy
corrugate at virgin prices i should be
able to buy p ET at virgin prices and
what i've done is just backed in to the
notion that there's a lot less supply
than there is demand for this material
and what i want to do is get the supply
of the material because I believe that
this if the supply that material comes
up the price comes down it creates a
whole other industry I think yeah Kim
thank you very much and and I I was
watching a brief clip this morning while
making coffee on Good Morning America
and the a pediatric endocrinologist was
was speaking about what he was calling
one of the most toxic foods that we eat
which is sugar and his viewpoint and
associated with diabetes and and obesity
hypertension heart disease and and also
used statistics that we were consuming
up to several hundred pounds per person
of sugar per year and I wondered how
your you are dealing with that and how
you are are internalizing that and
thinking about your product as an
alternative to sugar that you know would
be in a way healthier I mean I don't see
it in your advertising but I'm just kind
of curious about why you would not
engage that issue more directly well
first of all my first observation for
you would be that if I was in the soft
drink industry today I wouldn't be very
comfortable because they're they've
really got a bull's-eye on their back on
sugar if you haven't seen it if you
haven't seen us talk about this in our
advertising you haven't seen a Nestle
Pure Life commercial because we go right
at it Nestle Pure Life is is the Lark
now the largest selling brand of bottled
water in the country and most of the
people that buy it our moms they make
the purchase decision for for water
about 70 or 80 percent of the time and
we've we've clearly hit a nerve with
them on this this morning I got a
question about about bottled water
versus tap water I'm agnostic about that
I believe people need to be drinking
more water it did it it was fine for us
for several
years before we discovered stuff with
sugar in it here's here's the reality I
said this morning when you talked about
sure this is just not one industry now
every man woman and child consumes 44
gallons per capita of carbonated
beverages a year in America we we are
the I don't include Israel because it's
just a small country but the America is
the only developed country in the world
where soft drink consumption is larger
than bottled water consumption soft
drink the good news is soft drinks
peaked at 55 gallons 10 years ago 54
gallons it's v 44 today during that time
bottled water went from 16 to 24 gallons
per capita which means we captured 80
percent of the consumption that soft
drink industry lost so when people talk
to me about tap water versus bottled
water that's a false choice because our
growth has all come from people not
drinking sugar soft drinks anymore I
wanted to be healthier but the reality
still existed versus 40 years ago we are
consuming 450 calories a day from
carbonated beverages from sugar
beverages I should say all sugar
beverages for hundreds of calories a day
and forty years ago it was 240 so we
virtually doubled our intake of sugar
beverages in the last 40 years in
America the Surgeon General two years
ago told me that the life expectancy of
Americans was going to decline 40 years
from now because every third child born
after the year 2000 is going to be
diagnosed with diabetes sometime in
their life now you know I talked about
because we don't have sugar in our
product I talk a lot about this I'm on
the Executive Board of the American
Beverage Association it's like being a
member of a club where they don't want
you but I'm past the age where I care so
what about Nestle global well this is
interesting so so I was up I was up
talking about moderation in beverage
consumption a couple years ago and I got
asked the the ubiquitous question of
wait a minute you work for Nestle they
sell lots of stuff with sugar in it and
we do Nestle has a global portfolio of
products that
indulgences products and and health
products but on every package we try to
give people information about what
they're ingesting and and that there
should be choice and moderation in the
things that we do and look I got four
kids do we have ice cream in the house
hell yes do we have Coke in the house
hell yes we have Gatorade in the house
hell yes but but I won't let my kids sit
down at the counter and drink 12 ounces
of soft drinks because y'all might just
as well put the sugar bowl in front of
them and say here have 10 teaspoons of
sugar because that's what's in it so so
it's not that we don't have those
products but my kids drink a lot more
water than they do sugar beverages and I
just think that's makes a lot of sense
hello okay so my question relates back
to what you were talking about about
getting your supply of reclaimed bottles
up to the place where you could drive
the price down in Manitoba and in Canada
consumers are heavy-duty recyclers it's
part of their DNA their recycling rate
is double what ours is at least what are
your thoughts around how dependent your
success is on changing consumer behavior
and do you have any thoughts about how
to do that it's a really good question
because Michael and I were talking about
this earlier if you most states don't
have any money to educate around
recycling where they have recycling
programs because most recycling programs
are starving is it is the great thing
about EPR is it's going to provide
enough money to have robust education
programs that have to go along with this
you know I was saying this morning that
we get 30% of our bottles back in the
United States for all beverages and the
reason why we do I discovered you know I
may be overly simplistic but it holds
together as far as I know because the
information is not that great in this
whole space we have curbside recycling
availability in what I consider a
strong way in only at most fifty percent
of the country and and the statistics
are fifty percent of those people don't
recycle often fifty percent of fifty
percent is 25% then throw in ten bottle
states and you get to 30 that's the
numbers for America and I think it's and
Reid and I discussed this a while ago
it's not only educational it's cultural
we've got we've got demographics and
psychographics where people just don't
give a rat's ass about recycling and we
have to find a way to change that in
Connecticut there's a bottle bill and is
also recycling with a track
I tried recycling down at the grocery
store and after about two years I made
$10 and I decided just as easy to put it
in with the recycle in the recycle bin
so once you have the kind of system
you're envisioning a separate bottle
bill goes away because now it's they
should go away but but it's like
somebody's blanket it's like a little
kids Mikey you know they don't want to
lose it because they don't know what its
gonna be replaced with today so we're
actually trying to not do this in bottle
bill states because I think they they're
gonna end up being last people worked a
long time to get those done but I
totally agree with you we don't take
them back to the store
we got a single stream recycling now
what's interesting about the expansion
where we put the deposit on bottled
water two years ago it took a million
dollars worth of material out of the
curbside bins that the guys that were
recycling used to support their curbside
programs so it's it's it's almost worked
across purpose let's be careful about
that because the processors like CRA and
Connecticut lost the money but the
municipalities didn't have to collect as
much okay so you have to be careful
about who it is that's losing money the
municipalities are not necessarily
losing money but but here's where we are
in Connecticut now we have we after two
years we've got about a 45 percent
Redemption rate on bottled water well I
would think it would be higher but I do
what you do and maybe
a lot of other people do so maybe the
effective rate because we have pretty
good recycling systems in Connecticut
pretty good availability curbside in
Connecticut
maybe the rates now in Connecticut 70 or
80 when I put a recyclable bottle in in
with the trash does somebody get back
that 2 cents or there's you know the
five cents well here's here's what I'd
say the it's not just its it's not just
that yes there's a there's a there's a
lot of fraud being perpetrated here and
the main the main amount of fraud is
really in the handling fees because the
under the laws we have to pay the
retailer in New York 3 cents a case and
two and a half cents or at about three
cents a bottle in New York two and a
half cents a bottle in Connecticut to
take it from the front of the store to
the back of the store and we have people
we found an operation that was actually
we have different different we have a
little stripe up on top of our labels
that shown on deposit and and we found
an operation where they had human beings
razoring off the red on the top of it to
get the three cents it's a it went from
being Italian mafia to Russian mafia but
but yes there's a tremendous amount of
fraud out there with these with these
container laws and we have a big problem
we have a 125 percent Redemption rate in
Maine that doesn't work very well I'm a
long-term yeah so so so I think that's
an look I could stand up here and tell
you all the reasons why I don't like
bottle bills but but that sounds
self-serving what I'm what I'm
advocating for is a larger system that
gets more material back
I haven't heard you mention the term
reverse logistics at all in your talk
and I'm trying to get a handle from what
you said on how important you think that
is for getting a good recycling system
right so that you don't have the problem
whereby people are making special trips
and therefore largely negating any
benefit that you get from recycling to
take the things to an appropriate
recycling center well I did address it
from the standpoint of there are people
who think that we should have a system
for bottles and a system for other stuff
and a system for this an assistant for
that 15 systems ultimately we'll get at
this logistics issue in a very negative
way
my-my-my Carter who's a private Carter
in the town where I live makes a once a
week separate trip to get my recyclables
at my house but I'm advocating EPR
because I think it's the most efficient
way to get the most material back one
trip versus a bunch of trips I don't
know if I'm answering your question
properly or not but but yes I think I
think you know in the class this morning
the professor said at the end I think we
should go for we should have two models
what's the ideal system and then what's
the most pragmatic system and it may be
ideal to have 15 different EPR systems
out there but from a pragmatic
standpoint we need the least cost most
efficient system that gets the most
amount of material back did I get there
Nestle is a company that has creating
shell value at the core of these
principles and it's one of the main
proponents of creating shared value and
within that it has nutrition water and
Rural Development as a three dimensions
and one approach what is Nesta doing
globally for water and how is it
creating how does he tie it up with
creative trade value well water happens
to be the single issue that the chairman
of the company is focused on Peter
Brabeck and he chairs the United Nations
group on water sustainability and water
management globally the the I said this
morning
that we're gonna run out of water before
we run out of oil in this world and and
because our population is gonna double
40 years from now we do not manage our
water resources properly today if we
manage water the way we're managing it
today
we will not be able to feed the people
that live on this planet 40 years from
now so the biggest the biggest looming
issue in our Chairman's mind beyond of
anything else is is water resource
management
he thinks it's a bigger issue than
carbon it's a bigger issue than than
than oil usage and if you don't have to
look very far to see how we subsidize
water in America today we charge less
for it in municipalities than it cost to
maintain the infrastructure we we pay
farmers to grow crops that are not there
there are not water efficient we grow
rice in the desert in California so
people can keep their water rights
use-it-or-lose-it out in California and
and we're depleting major aquifers in
this country because we're not
sustainably using the water supplies
that we have today so we are we are very
vocal advocates for water sustainability
and part of our rural development is to
to teach people to irrigate crops more
efficiently to use less water to grow
more on on the land that they that
they're irrigating did I get there
okay yeah let's do one more question
first of all I've I've heard you a
couple times speak and I always
appreciate the transparency in the
director and the direct this so I have a
different sort of piggybacking on what
Heather asks in terms of the community
culture behavioral shift and your effort
now with reinventing recycling where do
you see the either the biggest blockades
or challenges in getting that level of
collaboration happening on the corporate
culture shift and if you wanted to offer
you know who do you see as your
strongest allies and that and are there
you know folks that we should know about
who may be oppositional to those efforts
I think coca-cola is is is relatively
close to our thinking on EPR most of the
rest of the consumer products companies
are not my my belief is that through our
efforts we will create enough dialogue
around this issue and enough ancillary
support from interested NGOs like as you
saw NRDC etc that ultimately to oppose
something that makes sense is going to
look stupid
and it's not going to reflect well on
these companies part of the
responsibility of CEOs like myself is to
look at the future see what's coming and
and get on board so that you're you end
up being in the right place when I
joined the the the American Beverage
Association I've joined twice now I quit
the first time because all these guys
did was fight bottle bills they didn't
offer any other solutions I said if you
look shrill if all you do is oppose and
don't offer another solution and that's
how I see GMA today frankly they're
they're opposed to it with no other
solutions frankly in my view they're
hiding out right now you can't find any
of those companies that's making a
serious effort at improving recycling in
America the beverage industry is the
only
place now is starting to see the light
on this issue but it goes way beyond the
beverage industry every single one of us
uses corrugate every single one of us
has printed paper of some kind and we
can use this material again but we have
to get it back
the thing about plastic a thing about
paper we can use it over and over and
over again it's kind of infinite
lifecycle if we just get it back and use
it again and I just think to stay on the
other side of this issue is not going to
reflect well at some point in time in
the future we have to move the needle on
recycling in America who's gonna stand
up and be part of the solution and who's
going to stand there and and and be
obstructionist about it well not note
I'd really like to thank Jim Jeffrey for
coming here and